Marine, présidente!
- En territoire ami
- (foule): Marine, présidente!
Marine, présidente!
LOUIS ALIOT,
- Bienvenue à Perpignan!
Qui a déjà fait le choix du
changement.
- Le maire, Louis Aliot, du
rassemblement national.
Perpignan, je ne doute pas que
demain, Marine le fera
la France.
- (foule): Marine, présidente!
- Ses partisans la v
- La candidate promet de mieux
s'occuper du bien-être des
actuel.
MARINE LE PEN, candidate
élection présidentielle
enrichi le pays, pardon!
(huée de la foule)
Mais on ne parlerait pas de
- (foule): On va gagner!
On va gagner!
- L'une des priorités de
la population. Marine Le Pen a
joué cette carte à fond,
en sillonnant la France.
(cris de joie)
JEAN-YVES CAMUS, politologue
Fondation Jean-Jaurès (Paris).
- À la rencontre des Français
ordinaires ou de ceux qu
mal à boucler les fins de mois,
et puis qu'avec la guerre en
une période où on nous promet
une hausse généralusususususus
les produits de consommation
courants, y compris
c'est à ceux-là que Marine
Le Pen s'a
- Et il remarque
qu'elle se dévoile davantage
donner un visage plus humain.
-  c c c c c contraste avec
la dureté de ses propositions.
Et puis, du même coup, comme
le paysage avec des propositions
dures, mais aussi un
est extrêmement tranchant,
Marine Le Pen a pu se payer
le luxe, si j'osouououououououos
propositions : "Enfin, ce n'est
pas humainrorororororop dur!"
- (foule): Zemmour, président!
- Même si, sur le fond,
Marine Lanananananananananananae
Reconquête, exemple sur
l'immigration,
- Deviendront Français ceux,
et seulement ceux qui méritent
de le devenir.
(acclamations)
- ... sur la forme, elle a
poursuivi la dédiabolisation du
parti hérité de son père,
Jean-Marie, en étant plus posée.
Bien des électeurs vont voter
Le Pen pour la première fois.
- J'avais toujours dit : Jamais!
Mais... Maintenant, il y a pire.
Il y a Zemmour.
- Je veux voter Marine Le Pe
parce que pendant cinq ans,
on a eu Macron et on ne veut pas
ravoir Macron au gouve
Ça suffit!
♪ ♪ ♪
- L'extrême droit
popularité en France, au-delà,
du socle habituel, qui comprend
notamment les èèèèèèèères,
populaires.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Le Rassenanananananananal a
déjà en tête la bataille du
deuxième tour. Tout en
averti'e'e'e'e'e'e'e'est encore
joué pour le premier tour.
Marine Le Pen lance un appel à
la mobilisation. Elle invite
crcrcrcrcrcrcrcrcroient en son
projet à se rendre aux urnes en
disant : "Quand on est patriote,
on ne s'abstient pas."
Ici Anyck B
Radio-Canada, à Perpignan